Okay, in this section, let's review some core concepts.
And we'll begin with importing animations.
When importing animations, there are a few things that are important for you to know.
First is that we're going to be using the FBX file format to import.
And we're going to do that directly from the Content Browser inside Unreal Engine.
Things to note here is that when you import an FBX file, Unreal Engine will triangulate
the mesh associated with the rig that you are trying to bring in for that animation.
If it's the first time you're importing, click Import on the Content Browser.
Select the FBX that you want to bring in.
And the first time you import a whole new character, you'll need to make sure that
the mesh itself and skeleton are imported together.
The skeletal mesh needs to be checked on in the FBX import options, as does the import
mesh option.
When importing animations, you have a few options to choose from when it comes to bringing
in your animation.
Starting with your animation length.
The options to choose from are the exported time, which is pretty much the whole animation,
the animated time, which is just the animated parts.
So if you start on frame 12 and give yourself a few frames to warm up without any actual
animation or keyframes, those warm up frames will be cut off.
Next is the set range, which allows you to manually select the frames that you want to
import.
The only problem with the set range is that you cannot do more than one set range import
at a time.
If you have multiple animations on a single timeline, you will need to manually select
the frames for each section that you want to import.
Next, you have the option to choose the sample rate, and you must make sure that you check
on import bone tracks.
Some helpful importing tips for you is that the transform option will fix incorrect rotations
from 1 DCC into Unreal Engine.
It will also give you the option to fix any scaling issues that you might have.
You also have the option of importing a uniform scale, which should correct any scaling issues
you might find when bringing in your asset.
Under the miscellaneous section, you might want to check on force front X axis to correct
the position so that you use Unreal Engine's Z up axis.
To use Unreal Engine's preferred unit of measurement, which is centimeters, you want to convert scene
Now, if you're bringing in animations for old skeletons, you just import that like normal.
Select the skeleton you want, choose the animation length, and if the skeleton is exactly the
same, then it should be pretty straightforward.
If not, you may have to retarget it with the new Retargeting toolset.
When adding purchased animations to the Library tab, just add the project directly or add
your animations to a different project and migrate just the specific animations that
you are interested in using in your project.
Now, your animation will probably need to be retargeted, and that's because it likely
comes with its own skeleton that doesn't match exactly what you're going to find in the
SKMany or SKQuin character rigs, or the metahumans that you might be building and bringing into the engine.
OK, that's it for this review section of Core Concepts, Importing Animations.
In the next section, let's review a few Sequencer Fundamentals.